hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning spoilers ahead
today i'm gonna explain a 2007 american
action and thriller movie called die
hard 4.0 or live free or die hard
the movie begins with a group of cyber
terrorists launching attacks on hackers
they send a virus that wipes the
computer's data then when the hacker
presses the delete button it explodes
then they cause an outage to the fbi
cyber security division causing miguel
bowman the deputy director to track down
potential hackers that may cause the
outage the instruction reaches john
mclean an nypd senior detective who is
attempting to communicate with lucy his
estranged daughter who is making out
with her boyfriend
john is tasked to pick up a local hacker
named matthew farrell and deliver him to
washington dc to be interrogated as with
other hackers matthew's computer is
hijacked and he is about to press the
delete button but luckily john knocks on
his door catching his attention
while they converse the terrorists
waiting outside matthew's apartment to
ensure it blows up feel something is off
and they attempt to storm inside and
finish the mission by themselves
john saves matthew and they successfully
escape heading for washington d.c
the terrorists are sent by mylang who
works for her boyfriend thomas gabriel
they send a helicopter to fetch the
surviving men not defeated by john
meanwhile the fbi tracks their potential
list of suspects being killed off one by
one with seven dead people so far
thomas launches a massive cyber attack
on the country he and his team hijacks
the transport system and disrupts the
traffic light system initiating car
crashes at road intersections and
sending the roads to complete gridlock
then they hack into the financial system
to crash down the stock market and sound
false anthrax alarms at government
institutions
matthew and john trapped in the traffic
get out of their car and continue on
foot after john realizes all the traffic
lights are green indicating something is
off with a traffic system they reach the
fbi's crisis center disrupted by the
anthrax alarms and meet bowman who is
trying to manage the crisis
matthew claims he does not know about
any of the dead hackers when he is shown
their photos
the terrorists then broadcast a
threatening video across all news
channels consisting of clips of you s
president speeches
matthew deduces that they are trying to
do a fire sale which the fbi despises
jod asks what a fire sale is to which
matthew answers that it is a massive
strategic cyber attack launched on vital
infrastructure in three steps
firstly the traffic system then the
financial system then vital utilities
such as electricity and gas bowman sends
matthew to be interrogated by the fbi
escorted by john and another agent along
the way john exclaims that he knows
matthew is lying about not recognizing
the dead hackers
matthew explains that he helped write a
mutating encryption algorithm for my and
those dead hackers were his competitors
the code is written by a lot of people
but it will only take several bad guys
to implement the code and execute the
fire sale
while asking for a safe route through
the city the terrorists intercept the
police car's communication and deduce
that matthew is still alive
my impersonating a dispatcher gives them
false instructions leading them right
into her trap
however matthew recognizes her voice and
deduces that the communication system
has been compromised
john threatens my through the radio to
which thomas replies by reading his
personal data then the terrorists send
an armed helicopter to shoot at them
jon drives into a tunnel where thomas
can hijack its system causing traffic
chaos and a power outage
jon gets an idea to drive the police car
straight into the helicopter waiting for
them at the tunnel exit effectively
destroying it the only survivor rand
reports to thomas and claims that jon
and matthew are dead
actually they are still alive and are
heading toward the new york police
department which currently is in total
chaos the officers could not help jon
and matthew since they are overwhelmed
by the angry citizens so the two head
out to figure out a way on their own
the terrorists proceed with their next
plan
led by emerson they infiltrate the
national data administration facility
once they are inside the facility my
poses as an fbi agent with a few other
people and heads out using a helicopter
they also knock off the satellite
networks and landlines cutting all fbi
communications
john attempts to contact bowman but
matthew warns him that his phone might
have been tracked so he uses a
stranger's phone while making the call
the terrorists broadcast a threatening
video again this time showing the white
house blown up to pieces
both john and bowman rush outside to see
the real condition of the white house
which is still standing
desperate jon asks matthew to put
himself in the terrorist shoes and
deduce their next move
matthew explains that even though the
attacks can be launched remotely vital
infrastructure has a closed circuit
system that needs to be hacked from
within so they should be physically
present in those facilities to hack them
he guesses that they will head to a gas
utility main hub in west virginia they
hijack a car and matthew contacts the
emergency service to remotely start it
claiming to be in a traffic incident
matthew's guess is correct since the gas
hub is where maya and her team are
heading
arriving there jon single-handedly
defeats mai's men and faces her while
they fight matthew hijacks back into the
hub system to reverse what the
terrorists have done
mai falls to her death after an intense
fight in the elevator shaft
thomas worrying about her calls her to
his surprise jon picks up the call
matthew hacks into the system to obtain
thomas image and sends it to the fbi
bowman recognizes thomas as his former
co-worker
devastated by mai's death enraged thomas
re-routes gas to the main hub with the
aim to destroy it killing jon and
matthew
he then instructs his team to trigger a
massive power outage along the east
coast
matthew gets an idea to contact another
top hacker codenamed warlock whom he
thinks can help them
they take a helicopter to head to
warlock's house
after identifying his house as the only
one with light still on they meet him
actually named freddie who is reluctant
to talk to a cop
he explains to them that thomas gabriel
was the former department of defense
employee who warned the government that
the country's cyber system is vulnerable
to cyber warfare but his ideas got him
fired he also explains that the piece of
code matthew helped wright was used to
access social security data at a
facility in woodlawn
however studying the facility's layout
they realized that it has cooling towers
an exaggerated feature for a facility
that contains social security data
freddie hacks into the system alarming
thomas and his men
they establish a live communication
channel with both parties able to hack
into each other's cameras
thomas locates lucy and uses her as a
bargaining point with john
meanwhile thomas kills all his engineers
but one trey before he proceeds to his
next move
john goes to woodlawn without inviting
matthew but matthew insists on coming
along and helping as much as he can
meanwhile bowman discovers the woodlawn
facility from his bosses who keep the
fact from him because he is not
authorized to know it however thomas
knows about the facility as he was the
one who designed it the fire sale would
trigger all financial data to be
downloaded to the facility making a
backup which thomas can use for whatever
he pleases
bowman instructs his men to find him a
helicopter so he can head to woodlawn as
fast as he can
john and matthew arrive at the facility
but are separated after an encounter
with thomas men
matthew recognizes his own algorithm
used to encrypt the data but is caught
by emerson
he claims that the terrorists need him
to decrypt it so frustrated trey and
thomas take him hostage along with lucy
john communicates with thomas using one
of his dead henchmen's radio exclaiming
that he will come for him and save his
daughter
he knows that thomas fears him because
lucy is being kept alive as a bargaining
point against him
thomas thinks john is underestimating
him and prepares an evacuation he
transports himself lucy and matthew
inside a government truck heading out of
the facility
john follows them by hijacking a
semi-trailer
thomas and his men realize that then he
hacks into the radio system of an f-35
plane sent by bowman to destroy the
woodlawn facility to give false
instruction to fire at john's truck
after an intense shooting near a bridge
the helicopter falls along with john but
he survives
thomas arrives at a nearby hangar where
he threatens matthew to solve his code
by shooting his knee and aiming the gun
point at lucy jon arrives at the right
time taking down thomas men except for
emerson
however he is shot on the shoulder and
then retreats to the back of a car
lucy finds a moment to grab emerson's
gun and shoot him while matthew hides
behind a stack of boxes and does not
finish his code
thomas captures jon standing closely
behind him positioning his gun on john's
shoulder
john pulls the trigger causing a bullet
to travel through his shoulder right
towards thomas hart instantly defeating
him
matthew grabs a gun and lurches to shoot
at emerson
the fbi arrives at the scene evacuating
jon lucy and matthew
john converses with lucy who takes a
romantic interest in matthew
he then approaches matthew and thanks
him for saving lucy's life despite
claiming he is not the hero type like
jon
although jon jokingly threatens him to
not flirt with lucy he asks about her
anyway
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching